GILBERT STRANG: OK.
We're still talking about first
order differential equations
with a dy dt.
And there is still a gross term
proportional to the balance.
This might be the interest
that's added on to y.
And then there is
input, a source term,
of deposits being
made all the time.
So I'm looking to solve
that differential equation.
And this is the best
possible function
for differential equations.
Exponentials.
Because the derivative of
exponential is exponential.
It's just easiest to work with.
And the output, the
solution is called
the exponential response.
That word response says what
comes out when e to the st
goes in.
And as before, we have some
starting deposit, y of 0.
Initial condition at time 0.
OK.
Here is the key point, that
with this nice source function,
the solution, or one solution,
a particular solution,
will be just a multiple of e
to the st. So all I have to do
is find that number, capital
Y, and I've got a solution
to that equation.
How do I do it?
Substitute this
into the equation
and solve for Y.
So let's do that.
The derivative of this, the
derivative of exponential
will bring down a factor s.
So there'll be a ys e to
the st from the derivative.
And that will have
to equal a times Y
e to the st, plus the source
term e to the st. good?
I just substituted it in.
Now, the nice thing, I
cancel, I divide by e
to the st, which is never 0.
So I divide by-- factor out
e to the st, factor that out.
It just leaves me with a 1.
So I have Y times s,
Y times a, plus 1.
So let me write that
equation so you see it.
That's just s minus
a times Y is 1.
Right?
I took a times Y and put it on
the left side of the equation.
So I've discovered the
exponential response.
1 over s minus a.
OK.
So I have a solution
to the equation.
That's not the end,
because that solution won't
match the initial condition.
So how do I match an
initial condition?
What I've found is a
particular solution,
and I need also the null
solution, the homogeneous
solution.
So the full solution, y of
t, is this Y particular.
So capital Y, I
now know is that.
So I have an e to
the st over-- I'm
putting in Y, the
right value of Y.
So that's the particular
solution that I've found.
Plus any null solution.
So remember, the null
solutions, that term is gone.
So the source is 0.
That's why the word null.
So I'm looking for the
solution to dy dt equal ay.
And the solutions
to dy dt equal ay
are e to the at,
times any number.
Because the right-hand
side is 0 now.
This is y particular.
And let me write that.
This is y particular, and this
is y null, or y homogeneous.
So that's the general solution.
The complete solution
has that form.
And now I can match y
equal y of 0 at t equal 0.
I put in t equal 0, I get y of 0
equals-- t equals 0, this is 1.
So 1 over s minus a.
And when t is 0,
this is 1, so plus C.
So now I know what C is.
And notice, C is not just y of
0, as sometimes in the past.
C is y of 0 minus this.
Are you ready now for
the complete solution
with satisfying the
initial conditions?
So now I'm going to--
this in the correct form.
This tells me what C has to be.
So I put it in and I
have this solution.
y of t is e the st over s minus
a, the easy one, plus C. Now,
C is y of 0 minus
1 over s minus a.
That's what we needed.
Times e to the at.
That's our answer.
I can make it look
a little nicer.
I want to.
I want to separate out the y
of 0 part, the part that's just
growing from the
initial condition,
from the part that is
coming from the source term.
So I just want to put
that together with this.
So I have the same
s minus a below.
Here is an e to the st above.
And I have a minus, that 1 over
s minus a, times e to the at.
And then I have this
term, which is growing.
Well, this is really good.
This is the part growing
out of the initial deposit.
I'm using, again, money in a
bank with additional deposits,
e to the st. And this
is the part coming
from those later deposits.
Initial part, and the
part coming from there.
So this is, again,
a null solution.
A multiple of e to the at.
This is another
particular solution.
Remember, there isn't just
one particular solution.
Any solution is a
particular solution.
And this is, I call that the
very particular solution.
Because it has the nice
property that it starts from 0.
So a t equals 0, that's
1 minus 1, I'm getting 0.
So I would call that y vp.
I'll introduce those letters,
not standard, for that part.
And then y homogeneous,
or y null, is this part.
OK.
Problem solved.
The exponential
grows in this way,
and the initial condition
grows directly that way.
OK.
The problem is solved
with one exception.
And now I have to take a
minute with that exception.
The exception is the formula
breaks down if s equals a.
If s equals a,
I'm dividing by 0.
My formula is falling apart.
And that's the
case of resonance.
So let me put over
here, s equal a.
That resonance.
And we always have
to expect that that's
a possibility, that
we're putting money
with the same exponential as
the natural growth of the money,
or whatever we're growing.
And our formula has to change.
You what you might
say it's infinite,
because I'm dividing by 0.
But notice the part
above is also 0.
If s equals a, this is e to
the st minus e to the at.
Those are the same.
So I have a 0/0 situation.
My formula is breaking
down, but it isn't dying.
It needs more thinking.
The case of resonance
needs to-- I
have to understand what
this is when s equals a.
Let me tell you what it is.
And then show you why.
So this is the case s equal a.
So if s equal a, then y very
particular plus y null space.
So it's this very
particular solution that
has to have a different form.
And here's the form it gets.
A factor t appears.
You just learn to recognize
resonance by that factor t.
So it'll be a t e to the at.
a is the same as s now,
so s doesn't appear.
So that's the solution
which starts from 0,
and it comes from the input.
And this is the part that
starts from y of 0 and grows.
So you see, eventually, this
is going to be the bigger one.
The resonant case,
it grows like e
to the at, with that little
bit extra growth of t.
OK.
So now I have a solution
in that special case
also, when s equals a.
All right.
Do you want to know how
this comes out of this
as s approaches a?
Let me take three minutes
to tell you about that.
It's L'Hopital's rule.
Do you remember
from calculus, 0/0,
the way to deal with that was
called by this guy's name,
L'Hopital?
Hospital, I guess.
Probably hospital in French.
And you this 0/0 expression.
It's a ratio of two things.
The top going to 0
when s goes to a,
because these become the same.
The bottom going to
0 when s goes to a.
And the right--
L'Hopital's cool idea
was you get the same
answer if you take
the ratio of the derivatives.
So L'Hopital says,
take the ratio
of the derivatives of the top
minus the derivative-- oh,
divided by the
derivative of the bottom.
And then let s go
to a in the end.
OK.
So I have to take
this derivative,
I have to take that
derivative with respect to s.
Often in calculus, it was an x.
Here it's an s.
No big deal.
So that derivative is--
You take the derivative
with respect to s.
We'll bring down--
ah, here comes the t.
The derivative of
s is t e to the st.
And the derivative
of this thing is 1.
And now I let s go to a.
Well, it's easy to
let s go to a now.
This thing approaches that.
I have the t e of
the at in the limit.
So L'Hopital's
rule was the reason
behind this formula
for resonance.
But again, I emphasize
that expect a factor t
when you have this resonance.
OK.
So that's the solution for the
best possible right-hand side
e to the st. Well, maybe
the best is a constant.
Second simplest
is an exponential.
Next, will come
sines and cosigns.
That's the next lecture.
Thanks.